bonjour jean marc heureuse de vous
retrouver dans les finales des relais
france alors coup de beaucoup de
restaurateurs va les garder ces terrains
ça l'enjeu est économique bien sûr mais
aussi politique
vous entend plus
jean marc sylvestre est ce que vous
m'entendez jean-marc oui là je vous
entends très bien alors comment est ce
qu'on va sortir de cette situation qui
est plutôt ubuesque pour certains et qui
met une fois de plus la mairie de paris
en difficulté oui c'est vrai gagné
daliot s'est mis dans une situation qui
est un peu déchiffrable alors qu'elle
est déjà pas au mieux à dans ces
sondages alors comment s'en sortir
d'abord il va falloir respecter la loi
et je crois que c'est ce que les
restaurateurs sont en train de faire là
actuellement il s'agit d'appliquer c'est
un nouveau règlement 1 qui avait été mis
en vigueur au 1er juillet 2021 pour
rebaptiser sa terrasse estivale est sûr
également gérer les extensions sur la
voie publique les extensions avait été
autorisé par la ville dans un contexte
exceptionnel vous le rappeliez pour
aider les commerçants et aussi pour
faire plaisir aux parisiens parce qu'ils
étaient friands de leurs terrasses il
remettait enfin le nez dehors alors le
règlement est à peu près le même
d'ailleurs dans toutes les villes
normalement ses terrasses pourront être
remonté le 1er avril prochain alors jean
marc a priori c'est assez simple mais
pourquoi ça grogne chez les
restaurateurs
ça grogne par tous avant et chez les
restaurateurs s'aggraver au conseil
municipal aussi parce que les
restaurateurs ont pris goût à cette
terrasse et cetera centre nous leur
coûterait pas très cher puisque et la
clientèle les ailes alors la situation
est compliquée parce qu'il ya plein de
situations qui sont très différentes et
qui sont très contradictoires d'abord
vous avez des restaurateurs qui avaient
déjà des terrasses avant le coc vide qui
paient le droit d'utiliser le domaine
public parce que c'est évidemment payant
que d'utiliser le domaine public pour
eux rien ne va changer sauf qu'il
voudrait bien que tout le monde soit
traité de façon équitable ce qui n'est
pas forcément le cas parce que et c'est
le deuxième point vous avez des
restaurateurs des cafés des brasseries
qui n'avaient pas de terrasse et qui ont
profité de la situation pour en
installer mais sans payer le droit
d'utiliser le domaine public alors à sud
est très pratique mais ça fait désordre
on passe sur les terrasses historique
qui en ont profités elle pour s'agrandir
centraux le virer sans même payer
troisième câble toutes ses terrasses
pourront être heureux dès le 1er avril
vous le disiez mais les restaurateurs
espèrent pouvoir toucher les même
surface que celle qu'ils avaient
personne ne parle de payer l'espace or
il va falloir pourtant régler cette
situation qui reste en suspens c'est un
peu cafouilleux tout ça oui quel est
l'enjeu pour la mairie de paris et
notamment dans les rangs a pour les
maris pour les mairies un enjeu
financier important
le domaine public ne pas être
privatisées ou alors il faut payer une
table sur paris la période de
confinement a représenté un manque à
gagner de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros pour les finances
municipales à les terrasses étaient
gratuites j'ajoute que s'était rassurée
occupent des places de stationnement qui
elle aurait pu aussi rapporté un péage
automobile ce qui n'a pas été le cas
puisqu'il du plat sont pas libres alors
pour la mairie de paris s'impose en plus
un problème quasi politique puisque sur
l'objectif c'est de réduire la
circulation automobile donc les
terrasses c'était une aubaine puisque ça
permet de supprimer des stations mais
les places de stationnement si on
supprime des places de stationnement ont
supprimé un peu on limite la circulation
je crois qu'en quelques temps la mairie
de paris a perdu 250 mille places de
stationnement en surface sont des
recettes en moins les terrasses ont
rendu service à la mairie mais elle ne
rapporte rien alors l'idée serait donc
de récupérer l'argent des terrasses mais
vous avez dans la majorité du conseil
municipal des gens qui considèrent que
ces terrasses ont un rôle social c'est
pas faut donc une forte pression pour ne
pas faire payer les bistrots et les
restaurants surtout ceux qui ont un
certain nombre de difficultés vous voyez
sur 10 le désordre n'est pas prête de se
clarifier alors quelle est la situation
des restaurateurs au brasseur et et
tafer dans tout cela ouais alors ça
c'est très difficile de s'y retrouver il
se plaignent beaucoup et ils veulent
travailler mais travaillent pas tous
comme il le souhaiterait globalement on
va être fait faut quand même être
honnête ça s'est pas trop mal passé ils
ont eu des aides ils ont été près les
fameux pge il y à du chômage partiel qui
a permis d'indemniser les salariés qui
naquit ne pouvait plus venir travailler
beaucoup ont profité de la crise
d'ailleurs pour investir pour s'adapter
ça se voit d'ailleurs quand on se balade
dans paris et le rebond à la sortie de
la crise a quand même été très fort très
profitable depuis le début juillet en
france je savais que 250 mille
établissements des restaurants en 2000
il ya des bars des brasseries 48 des
hôtels et des établissements nuit' 50000
tous ces gens là étaient concernés alors
tous les restaurants de vacances de la
côte atlantique et melita réel en fait
formidable saison avec un rebond
touristique exceptionnel les restaurants
situés en ville eux ont dû s'adapter le
click and collect télétravail qui a
changé beaucoup d'habitude on fréquente
moins les restaurants soit à midi soit
le soir et comme toujours bas les restos
les plus fragiles vont avoir du mal on
estime à 38 mille le nombre de
restaurants en en situation de risque de
fragilité et sans doute de fermeture
avec un autre problème c'est le manque
de main-d'oeuvre ça c'est un secteur qui
emploie près de 800 mille salariés on
estime que plus de cent mille salariés
ont disparu du secteur hôtelier
restauration où sont ils passés personne
ne sait beaucoup de restaurants fermés
un ou deux services non pas par manque
de clients mais par manque de salariés
le comble c'est qu'à pôle emploi et bien
je vous le dis on est super on a assez
peu d'informations pour dire éditions
passées alors ça ce phénomène là c'est
vrai dans l'hôtellerie c'est vrai dans
la restauration mais c'est aussi vrai
dans le bâtiment dans la mécanique c'est
la situation est assez paradoxal en
france on a une situation qui
macroéconomique mans va très bien la
bourse bat des records encore aujourd
hui encore hier le la situation de
l'emploi est plutôt tendue alors que
nous avons encore plus de 3 millions de
chômeurs nous sommes en pénurie
d'emplois nous cherchons plus d'un
million de personnes pour occuper des
postes dans les hôtels dans les
restaurants et je vous le disais dans le
bâtiment merci beaucoup je marque
l'édito de jean marc sylvestre c'est
tous les mercredis matin dans la
matinale de rtl france est à retrouver
sur les réseaux sociaux